as a nation we face a difficult few
weeks as we approach that that really
important day when we're going to see
things get better all of a sudden and
it's going to be like a burst of light I
really think and I hope our strength
will be tested and our endurance will be
tried but America will answer with love
and courage and ironclad resolve this is
the time for all Americans to come
together and do our part I appreciate a
lot of the media we've had a lot of
really good things said I think only
good things can be said when you look at
the job that's been done I just spoke
with Franklin Graham was an
extraordinary person and Samaritan's
Purse has been like so many others just
been amazing and so fast they did it so
fast
he's been doing that for a long time but
I think people are really seeing what
they have done Franklin Graham very
special family as we send plane loads of
masks and gloves and supplies to the
communities battling the plague and
that's what it is it's a plague we also
send our prayers we pray for the doctors
and the nurses for the paramedics and
the truck drivers and the police
officers and the sanitation workers and
above all the people fighting for their
lives in New York and all across our
land